die lage hat sich dramatisch geändert
man kann sagen alexander lukaschenko hat
die macht verloren
wenn sich in einer in seiner einer
solchen diktatur der innenminister vor
das volk stellt und sich entschuldigt
wenn gefangene freigelassen werden wobei
freigelassen da noch das falsche wort
ist wenn die die werden einfach
rausgeworfen krank wie sie sind
geschlagen und blutig dann als alexander
lukaschenko die macht schon längst nicht
mehr
es ist offensichtlich dass der diktator
irgendwie abgetaucht ist also er ist
seit dem wahlabend nicht mehr gesehen
worden er ist nicht mehr aufgetreten es
gibt keine tondokumente von ihm selbst
es gibt keine fotos von ihm keine
aktuellen videos niemand weiß wo
lukaschenko ist und das was in der
letzten nacht was gestern passiert ist
das ist der erste große sieg dieser
friedlichen revolution denn bis zum
abend vorher ist geprügelt worden sind
dies ist geschossen worden ist
wir hatten die berichte aus dem rest das
so scharf geschossen worden ist die
leute sind von den straßen weg geschickt
worden und in die gefängnisse geworfen
worden oder weil die gefängnisse
überfüllt waren
außerhalb von minsk einfach auf der
straße rausgeworfen worden so dass sie
den 50 60 oder 100 kilometer zurück
laufen mussten das hat sich dramatisch
geändert gestern sind in minden zb und
landesweit die frauen auf die straße
gegangen
wir haben die bilder gesehen von frauen
die an den straßen stehen mit weißen
blumen mit weißen rosen und mit anderen
blumen und das war der wendepunkt das
war der kipp punkt landesweite streiks
und die frauen auf der straße wenn die
mutter wenn die schwestern wenn die
freundinnen und die tanten auf die
straße gehen dann ist auch ein
machtapparat der von lukaschenko
schlicht und ergreifend machtlos er die
macht verloren und nur die frage ist wer
macht jetzt gewinnen und laut radar sind
ja russische maschinen flugzeuge in
belarus gelandet was hat das jetzt zu
bedeuten
ja das was er hier sind das ist die
flugroute von einheit von einer tupolew
134 ak das ist eine maschine des
russischen verteidigungsministeriums die
ist vor anderthalb tagen schon geflogen
jetzt sind weitere maschinen
hinterhergekommen soweit wir das auf
leitherer danach folgen konnten und
recherche gruppen das auch nach verfolgt
haben die große frage ist bringen sie
sachen oder holen sie sagen also holen
sie zum beispiel lukas schenkel zeug
raus oder aber bringen sie sachen rein
die wie zb militärtechnik das flugzeug
das wir jetzt gerade gesehen haben das
ist eine maschine die wird normalerweise
von der silhouette genutzt also von den
oberen von minister stellvertretende
minister oder manchmal kommen die
gleichen rein aber auch die gruppe
wagner eine söldnergruppe nutzt das es
ist alles ein alarmzeichen es ist aber
auch ein zeichen dafür dass die dass die
weißrussische regierung dass belarus
nicht mehr wirklich von lukaschenko
regiert wird die sind komplett abhängig
von moskau in moskau braucht dieses land
aus ihrem eigenen verständnis als
schutzschild gegen den freien westen
wenn du sagst dass die opposition
gewonnen hat glaubt es wird ein
offiziellen rücktritt von lukas schenkel
geben
das hängt jetzt alles wirklich davon ab
wie die machtverhältnisse sind wir
können relativ schlecht reinschauen in
diesen diktatur apparat
es sieht so aus also auch die
gesundheitsministerin hat sich heute
entschuldigt und hat ein ende der gewalt
gefordert und sie kann damit ja auch nur
die polizei dann gemeint haben also in
diesen machtapparat scheint es eine
tektonische plattenverschiebung gegeben
zu haben
und das geht nur wenn du geschenke und
nicht da ist oder wirklich die zügel aus
der hand gegeben und irgendjemand hat
ihn entmachtet die frage die wir
momentan nicht beantworten können ist
wer war das ist dass moskau sind es die
eigenen leute und die opposition krank
momentan daran dass sie zwar einen
großen sieg hat das war die leute auf
der straße jetzt gewonnen haben aber es
gibt keine zentrale figur momentan das
könnte der verlust geringer seien die
ist allerdings dann auch dann noch im
ausland
und wir wissen nicht ob unter den
freigelassenen jetzt auch ihr mann ist
der ursprung der
präsidentschaftskandidat war
wenn der aus dem gefängnis kommt dann
hätte die opposition wieder eine
zentrale eine richtige heldenfigur oder
wenn ihr an oskar zurück kommt auch das
kann sie erst wenn ihr mann wirklich
frei ist wenn sie weiß dass dessen
sicherheit ist ich blicke jetzt müssen
nach moskau gehen und was wladimir putin
dort entscheidet entscheidet er sich für
einen bürgerkrieg hier oder aber
versucht er eine scheinbar vom volk
gewählte machtübernahme durch einen
anderen durch einen moskauer
repräsentanten durchzusetzen
und was ist gerade gesagt die
oppositionsführern hält sich aktuell im
ausland auf genauer in litauen und wir
haben den litauischen außenminister zum
interview getroffen
wir haben gestern gesprochen und sie
sollten
sie ist eine junge frau die vorher noch
nie in der politik war und deshalb mit
einem solchen druck nie gerechnet hätte
sie wurde sieben stunden festgehalten
und wir wissen nicht wie sie behandelt
wurde
vielleicht wurde sie sogar erpresst und
deshalb sollte sie sich davon erst
einmal erholen die menschen auf der
straße haben nichts mit politik oder
parteien zu tun
es ist nicht nur minsk es gibt etwa 30
städte im land und sie brauchen nicht
viel
ihnen muss gehör geschenkt werden
es ist schon absurd ist dass wir
versuchen die regierung zu überzeugen
mit ihren eigenen leuten zu reden
wir wissen nicht wann die bevölkerung an
die grenzen ihrer geduld kommt man kann
darüber diskutieren wie die menschen für
ihre rechte kämpfen
aber sie riskieren viel
es drohen ernste konsequenzen den job
verlieren der schule verwiesen werden
familienmitglieder werden bedroht das
ist wirklich nicht einfach
es ist nicht einfach zu kämpfen aber
trotzdem tun sie es es ist wichtig zu
handeln morgen haben wir eine
sondersitzung mit außenministern der
europäischen union
und ich hoffe dass wir über maßnahmen
reden denn wir sind uns einig darüber
das ist politische konsequenzen geben
muss und beziehungen mit diesem land
überdacht werden müssen ich glaube dass
es möglich ist über individuelle
sanktionen gegen die verantwortlichen zu
sprechen
ich rede von wirtschaftlichen sanktionen
aber nicht zum leidwesen der menschen
vor ort
ich sehe zwei vergehen den wahlbetrug
und den einsatz unverhältnismäßiger
gewalt peter wir haben den außen es
gerade gehört welche rolle spielt denn
dieses kleine land liter in dem konflikt
zunächst einmal ist ein ganz wichtiger
nachbarstaat und es ist ein
demokratischer staat ein mitglied der
europäischen union also damit zielgebiet
also und auch projektionsfläche für
viele leute in weißrussland das ist ein
demokratischer nachbarstaat der mit
ihnen zusammen früher in der sowjetunion
war und der es geschafft hat der
wirklich erfolgreich ist der
demokratisch ist und der wirklich
weltweit anerkannt ist und natürlich
wird die opposition auch unterstützt aus
diesem nachbarland es ist ein
zufluchtsort dort sind hin
dorthin sind auch oppositionelle
geflohen und und daher polen ist ganz
wichtig liter und ist ganz wichtig aber
der blick richtet sich auch auf
deutschland
deutschland ist ein großes land
deutschland ist die wichtigste
demokratie und die größte
wirtschaftsmacht in europa gibt und
dorthin wird und wirklich wirklich
geschaut und man wartet auf ein
positives zeichen aus berlin